[Music]
the movie trilogy by peter jackson went
down in history and the book series by
j.r.r tolkien
is unrivaled anyway clearly we're
talking about the lord of the rings
after the last lord of the rings movie
was released in 2003 and the hobbit
trilogy has been concluded more than
seven years ago
it's about time for new content that's
what amazon thought in 2017
and so they embarked on one of the
biggest serious projects of
all time namely its own the lord of the
rings series
how big it is what it has to do with the
film trilogy and what you can expect in
general
is what we're presenting to you today in
our latest original so
enjoy our new episode
naturally the first point of discussion
is the storyline as we already know this
series will not be a remake of a former
story and will stand completely on its
own two feet
there will be a clear gap of about three
thousand years between frodo's
adventures and the upcoming series which
is why we can definitely speak of a kind
of prequel smart fans of the franchise
will know that we're in the so-called
second age of middle-earth
the most significant evidence for this
are a total of four maps of middle earth
officially published on twitter
which disclose some information about
the setting for example you can
recognize the fortress of minnesota
which was taken in the year 2002 of the
third age and subsequently named minis
morgul
another place marked on the map is
mini-sanor the capital of gondor which
was later renamed to minas tirith and
has existed since the year 3220 in the
second age
you can also see the small island of
tall fellas at the lower end of the
coast it was destroyed after the
numenoreans were wiped out in the second
age and as a result it became
barren and very hilly as can also be
seen on the map if you look closely
so there is enough proof that there are
thousands of years between the series
and the film trilogy at the beginning of
this year the fan page of the
onering.net
also revealed their first official
synopsis which was actually confirmed by
amazon via twitter
according to the synopsis amazon is
reawakening the heroic legend of the
legendary second age
the series is meant to take the vero
back to an era of great powers falling
and rising kingdoms as well as unusual
heroes and reveal the greatest
villain ever to come out of talking
spanning of course we all know who's
meant right here nearly none other than
sauron himself the synopsis goes on to
say that the evil will grow stronger in
a time of peace and that it will have to
deal with an ensemble of old and new
characters
in addition more or less the whole world
of middle earth will be explored
in this regard there are again a few
theories one of them being that we can
mainly expect breathtaking high seas
adventures
this is not unlikely after all the
island kingdom of numenor is located in
the far
south west of the map in a place only
ships can reach by sea moreover the plot
of the first of probably five seasons
will be told in eight episodes of still
unknown length we are definitely looking
forward to more updates concerning the
plot and the setting and will of course
keep you up to date in our weekly news
the cast is also not to be neglected of
course
at least three returning characters who
are officially confirming their roles
will be seen in the series
on the one hand there is the elf
galadriel who is no longer embodied by
kate blanchet but instead by
morphit clark she's certainly one of the
best known figures from middle earth and
now gets a clear rejuvenation thanks to
the 32 year old clark
the elf elrond and the villain sauron
are also part of the cast but without
any official confirmation
of the respective actors it is also very
likely that sauron s once in the book
will make use of his ability
as a shape shifter one of these guys is
the character anataro comes across as
very friendly
but only serves the sole purpose of
convincing the elves to forge the rings
as already hinted at the majority of the
cast consists of relatively unfamiliar
faces though there's marcella cavanaugh
who is expected to assume the new rule
of tyra as well as joseph molly who may
play the villain orrin
additionally there is robert aramaiya
who will probably take on the main role
of beldore
among many others just as with peter
jackson's trilogy they chose beautiful
new zealand as the filming location
unfortunately as with many other
productions not all went smoothly due to
the pandemic
filming had to be passed temporarily so
that up to 800 crew members had to be
sent home while production was at a halt
for
weeks for a project that is supposed to
cost over 1 billion us dollars already
this is of course no cakewalk happily
however production was resumed as soon
as possible and
is still in full swing the responsible
parties behind the camera are to begin
with
john d payne and patrick mckay who both
serve as serious developers and are the
creative minds behind the project
juan antonio baiona was responsible for
directing at least the first two
episodes with wayne yep and charlotte
branstrom assuming the director's
position in the following episodes
who's definitely not making a comeback
is peter jackson who refused to take a
leading position in the production
he will merely serve an advisory role
another interesting aspect for fans is
the budget which was briefly alluded to
earlier with an estimated 1 billion us
dollars the lord of the rings series
will be the most expensive series
production of
all time the filming rides alone are
said to have cost 250 million us dollars
on the other hand amazon will certainly
be receiving a nice amount of cash from
the new zealand government
since the streaming giant is entitled to
an estimated 116 million us dollars from
a national film funding scheme thanks to
the jobs
it generates locally
the release date of the series is still
an unanswered question for many fans
although shooting is slowly reaching its
end it is still not really certain when
the series will be available on amazon
prime video a release in the fourth
quarter of 2021 would be feasible which
would coincide perfectly with the cold
fall months
we also consider a later release in 2022
to be realistic as everything depends on
how smoothly filming goes on
as well as how many scenes need to be
reshot and so forth
in this regard we also hope to be able
to tell you a more exact time frame
soon that's it again with our latest
original episode
we hope you're now up to date on the
latest news and that you may even have a
little more anticipation for the
upcoming amazon series
feel free to write us in the comments
what you expect from the series and
subscribe to our channel if you want to
see more similar content
in the future thanks for watching and
see you next time
you